bonjour je suis franciscoostar l'ami des
stars directeur de la murriise et
aujourd'hui je vais vous donner trois
bonnes raisons de venir sur la soirée du
25 novembre à la
[Musique]
murise la première de ces raisons c'est
la journée de lutte contre les violence
fait aux femmes et là c'est important
d'y être et de montrer notre soutien à
cette noble cause deuxième chose deux AR
qui sont en train de monter monter
monter grimper dans l'humour Tania
duutel et Rosa Bernstein trème raison
mais ce soirl vous avez rien d'autre à
faire c'est chez nous qu' faut être à la
meurise le 25 novembre à trappe on
compte sur vous les tampon c'est blindé
de pesticides c'est pour rendre le coton
plus blanc déjà c'est hyper
raciste quand vous embrouillez avec
quelqu'un que vous connaissez pas dans
la rue votre réparti elle est meilleur
après dans votre tête quand vous êtes
chez vous